ou des enfants d'immigrants.
Chacun de nous avait un rêve en venant ici,
un rêve qui doit habituellement être réécrit
et doit toujours être réorienté.
Je faisais partie des chanceux.
Mon rêve révisé m'a conduite au travail que je fais aujourd'hui :
former les immigrants à se présenter à la fonction publique
et mener un mouvement pour la démocratie intégratrice.
Mais ne pensez pas que c'était facile,
que l'Amérique a ouvert ses larges bras et qu'elle m'a accueillie.
Elle ne le fait toujours pas.
En chemin, j'ai appris quelques leçons
que je voulais partager avec vous
parce que je pense que, ensemble,
nous pouvons rendre la démocratie américaine
meilleure et plus forte.
Je suis née en Inde,
la plus grande démocratie du monde,
et quand j'avais 4 ans,
ma famille a déménagé au Belize,
peut-être la plus petite démocratie du monde.
Et à l'âge de 17 ans,
j'ai déménagé aux États-Unis,
la meilleure démocratie du monde.
J'y suis venue pour étudier la littérature anglaise.
Quand j'étais enfant, j'avais le nez dans les livres.
J'ai pensé : pourquoi ne pas gagner ma vie en faisant cela à l'âge adulte ?
Mais après avoir obtenu mon diplôme universitaire
et un diplôme d'études supérieures,
je me suis retrouvée à passer d'un emploi moins idéal à un autre.
Peut-être c'était l'optimisme que j'avais envers l'Amérique
qui m'a fait prendre un certain temps pour comprendre
que les choses n'allaient pas changer.
La porte que je croyais ouverte
était, en fait, légèrement entrouverte,
cette porte de l'Amérique
qui serait complètement ouverte si vous aviez le bon nom,
la bonne couleur de peau,
les bons réseaux,
mais pourrait simplement vous claquer au nez,
si vous aviez la mauvaise religion,
la mauvaise couleur de peau.
Et je ne pouvais pas accepter cela.
J'ai donc commencé une carrière en tant qu'entrepreneur social.
J'ai démarré une organisation pour les jeunes gens comme moi -
j'étais jeune à l'époque où je l'ai démarrée -
qui tracent leur héritage depuis le sous-continent indien.
Dans ce travail, je suis devenue avocate
pour les sud-asiatiques et les autres immigrants.
J'ai exercé des pressions sur des membres du Congrès sur les questions politiques.
Je me suis proposée le jour des élections
pour faire des sondages à la sortie des urnes.
Mais je ne pouvais pas voter et je ne pouvais pas me porter candidate.
Donc, en 2000, quand il a été annoncé
que les frais de demande de citoyenneté allaient plus que doubler,
passant de 95 dollars à 225 dollars,
j'ai décidé qu'il était temps de postuler avant de ne plus pouvoir me le permettre.
J'ai rempli un long formulaire,
j'ai répondu aux questions sur mes affiliations actuelles et passées.
Une fois la demande soumise,
il fallait prendre mes empreintes digitales,
étudier pour un examen,
passer d'interminables heures à attendre.
Vous pourriez appeler cela un examen minutieux.
Et puis en décembre 2000,
j'ai rejoint des centaines d'autres immigrants
dans une salle à Brooklyn
où nous promettions notre loyauté
à un pays que nous avions longtemps considéré comme chez nous.
Mon voyage d'étudiante internationale à citoyenne américaine a pris 16 ans,
un court délai quand on le compare à d'autres histoires d'immigrants.
Et peu de temps après avoir pris cette étape formelle
pour devenir une Américaine,
les attentats du 11 Septembre 2001
ont changé le paysage de l'immigration pour les décennies à venir.
Ma ville, New York,
était vacillante et en voie de guérison
et au milieu de tout cela,
nous étions dans un cycle électoral.
Deux choses se sont produites
alors nous faisions face à la perte et la guérison à New York.
Les gens ont élu Michael Bloomberg maire de New York.
Nous avons également adopté par référendum
le Bureau des affaires des immigrants de la ville de New York.
Cinq mois après cette élection,
le maire nouvellement élu
m'a nommée la première commissaire des affaires des immigrants
pour ce poste nouvellement créé.
Je veux que vous reveniez à ce moment-là.
J'étais une jeune femme immigrante en provenance du Belize.
J'avais échoué dans divers emplois en Amérique
avant de commencer un organisme communautaire
dans le sous-sol d'une église dans le Queens.
Les attentats du 11 septembre ont envoyé des ondes de choc à travers ma communauté.
Les gens qui étaient membres de ma famille,
les jeunes gens avec qui j'avais travaillé
ont été victimes de harcèlement
dans les écoles, les lieux de travail et dans les aéroports.
Et maintenant, j'allais représenter leurs soucis
au sein du gouvernement.
Aucun travail ne m'a paru plus parfait pour moi.
Et voici deux choses que j'ai apprises quand je suis devenue commissaire.
Tout d'abord, les New-Yorkais bien intentionnés
faisant partie du gouvernement municipal
n'avaient aucune idée à quel point les immigrants étaient effrayés
par les forces de l'ordre.
La plupart d'entre nous ignorent la différence
entre un shérif, la police locale et le FBI.
Quand nous voyons quelqu'un en uniforme
passer dans nos quartiers,
nous sommes curieux, voire préoccupés.
Donc, si vous êtes un parent sans-papiers,
tous les jours quand vous dites au revoir à votre enfant,
vous les envoyez à l'école et vous allez travailler,
vous ne savez pas quelles sont vos chances
de les voir à la fin de la journée.
Parce qu'un raid à votre lieu de travail,
une rencontre fortuite avec la police locale
pourrait changer le cours de votre vie pour toujours.
Deuxièmement, j'ai appris que lorsque les gens comme moi,
qui comprennent cette peur,
qui ont appris une nouvelle langue, qui ont navigué dans de nouveaux systèmes,
quand des gens comme nous étaient assis à la table,
nous défendions les besoins de nos communautés
comme personne d'autre ne pouvait ou ne voulait le faire.
J'ai compris ce qu'était le sentiment de peur.
Les gens de ma famille le vivaient.
Les jeunes avec qui j'avais travaillé étaient harcelés,
non seulement par leurs camarades de classe,
mais aussi par leurs professeurs.
Mon mari, petit ami d'alors,
réfléchissait à deux fois avant de mettre un sac à dos ou se faire pousser la barbe
parce qu'il voyageait beaucoup.
Ce que j'appris en 2001, c'est que mon vote comptait
mais que ma voix et mon point de vue avaient également de l'importance.
Et ce sont ces trois choses -
les votes, les voix et les points de vue des immigrants -
qui, je pense, peuvent aider à rendre notre démocratie plus forte.
Nous avons le pouvoir
de changer le résultat des élections,
d'introduire de nouvelles questions dans le débat politique
et de changer le visage du leadership pâle, mâle et rassis
que nous avons dans notre pays aujourd'hui.
Donc, comment faire ?
Eh bien, parlons d'abord de votes.
Ce ne sera pas une surprise pour vous
que la majorité des électeurs en Amérique sont blancs.
Ce qui pourrait vous surprendre,
c'est qu'un électeur sur trois est noir, latino ou asiatique.
Voici où je veux en venir :
qui peut voter n'a pas d'importance, ce qui importe est qui vote.
En 2012, la moitié des Latinos
et des électeurs américains d'origine asiatique
n'ont pas voté.
Ces votes ne comptent pas seulement dans les élections présidentielles.
Ils comptent dans les élections locales et régionales.
En 2015, Lan Diep,
le fils aîné de réfugiés politiques en provenance du Vietnam,
s'est présenté à un poste du conseil municipal de San José.
Il a perdu l'élection par 13 votes.
Cette année, il a dépoussiéré ses chaussures de campagne
et s'est représenté à ce poste.
Et cette fois, il a gagné par 12 voix.
Chacun de nos votes compte.
Et quand des gens comme Lan sont assis à la table de la politique,
ils peuvent faire une différence.
Nous avons besoin de ces voix.
Nous avons besoin de ces voix
en partie parce que le leadership américain
ne ressemble pas aux résidents américains.
Il y a plus de 500 000 bureaux locaux et étatiques en Amérique.
Moins de 2% de ces bureaux sont détenus
par des Américains d'origine asiatique ou latino,
les deux plus grands groupes d'immigrants dans notre pays.
Dans la ville de Yakima, dans l’État de Washington,
où 49% de la population est d'origine latino,
il n'a jamais eu un latino dans le conseil municipal
jusqu'à cette année.
Trois latinas nouvellement élues ont rejoint
le conseil municipal de Yakima en 2016.
L'une d'elles est Carmen Mendez.
C'est la première de sa famille à être allée à l'université.
Elle a grandi en partie en Colima, au Mexique
et en partie à Yakima.
Elle est mère célibataire et défenseure de la communauté.
Sa voix au conseil municipal de Yakima
prône les intérêts de la communauté latino
et le droit de tous les résidents de Yakima.
Et elle est un modèle pour sa fille
et d'autres latinas.
Mais la troisième ressource la plus inexploitée dans la démocratie américaine
est le point de vue que les immigrants apportent.
Nous nous sommes battus pour être ici.
Nous sommes venus
pour des opportunités économiques et éducatives,
pour la liberté politique et religieuse,
nous sommes venus à la poursuite de l'amour.
Ce dévouement,
cet engagement pour l'Amérique,
nous les apportons également au service des gens.
Des gens comme Athena Salman,
qui la semaine dernière a gagné les primaires
pour un siège au Parlement d'Arizona.
Son père a grandi dans la bande de Gaza
et a déménagé à Chicago
où il a rencontré sa mère.
Sa mère est en partie italienne,
en partie mexicaine et en partie allemande.
Ensemble, ils ont déménagé en Arizona et ont construit une vie.
Athena, lorsqu'elle est arrivera au Parlement,
va se battre pour le financement de l'éducation
qui va aider à donner un coup de pouce aux familles comme la sienne
pour qu'ils atteignent la stabilité financière
que nous recherchons tous.
Les votes, les voix et les points de vue des immigrants
doivent être inclus dans la démocratie américaine,
nous devons y travailler.
Ce n'est pas que mon travail, c'est aussi le vôtre.
Et ça ne sera pas facile.
On ne sait jamais
ce que fera un nouveau facteur dans l'équation.
Et c'est un peu effrayant.
Vous avez peur que je prenne votre place à la table
et j'ai peur de ne jamais obtenir une place à la table.
Et nous avons tous peur
de perdre ce pays que nous connaissons et aimons.
J'ai peur que vous me retiriez ce pays
et vous avez peur que je vous le retire.
Cela a été une rude année électorale,
un rappel que les gens avec mon passé d'immigration
pourrait être supprimés au gré d'un leader.
Mais je me suis battue pour être dans ce pays
et je continue de le faire chaque jour.
Donc, mon optimisme ne faiblit jamais,
parce que je sais qu'il y a des millions d'immigrants comme moi,
devant moi, derrière moi et tout autour de moi.
C'est notre pays aussi.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)